pour en parler avec nous philippe muray
re économistes chili pereire bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation directe sur rt france alors
l'exécutif s'étonne puisque l'arbitrage
sur le seuil des 120 mille euros du
futur système universel date de plus
d'un an à l'époque on n'avait pas
entendu le medef
pourquoi maintenant selon pourquoi
maintenant j'en ai aucune idée parce que
je suis pas dans le secret des
négociations un qui étaient des
négociations à ses cachets mais bon on
peut comprendre que le medef soit soient
inquiets et d'ailleurs ça fait beaucoup
de monde qui est inquiet puisque le
puisque le conseil d'état a dit qu'il y
avait un problème avec cette réforme
ainsi que les syndicats ainsi que tous
les français donc il ya plus grand monde
derrière macron en fait sur ce sujet le
problème effectivement c'est que une
bonne protection sociale c'est la
garantie qu vos salariés soient contents
ils restent bien en france or là on
parle de salaires qui sont environ 7500
euros nets donc des gens plutôt mobile
effectivement le savent avoir deux
conséquences importantes
c4est seront plus couverts par le
système de retraites par répartition au
delà d'un certain montant
donc ils vont être obligés de cotiser à
un système par capitalisation à mettre
de l'argent de côté pour le verser en
épargne-retraite pourquoi le medef
justement est contre ce système de
capitalisation
mais en fait c'est une financiarisation
comme le dit d'ailleurs françois avril
de la confédération générale des cadres
qui ont aussi opposé à la loi la réforme
des retraites c'est une financiarisation
des retraites sur ce sujet là avec tous
les risques qui vont avec
on évoquera sa si vous voulez et mais
c'est aussi un vrai problème d'ailleurs
une perte pour le système des retraites
puisque ces trois cent mille personnes
en fait tu cotises ça va faire un manque
de cotisation selon l'âge et recaro de
plus de 4 milliards d'euros par an c'est
étonnant que on voulait être comblé le
trou du système de retraite et qu'en
fait on creuse un trou de 4 milliard
d'euros par cette réforme
en fait le problème de la retraite par
capitalisation donc 4 milliards d'euros
par an ça veut dire que
si les salariés abondent ces 4 milliards
d'euros ce qui est la logique pour se
créer une retraite par capitalisation à
faire au bout de dix ans 40 milliards
d'euros qui seront en jeu dans le
système financier et qu'ils seront en
épargne retraite
le problème c'est que la retraite par
capitalisation a déjà existé en france
et elle a montré toutes ces nuisances
elle a été créée en 1910 était le
premier système de retraite nous pour
les employés le problème c'est que la
retraite par capitalisation est fragile
avec deux éléments qui peuvent la faire
chuter gravement c'est l'inflation qui
va rogner tous les actifs qu'ils ont
acheté et ou alors un krach sur les
marchés financiers et à l'époque en 1910
évidemment il ya eu la guerre de 14-18
beaucoup d'inflation par la suite est en
fait le système a été complètement
dépréciés et abandonné lorsqu'il avait
montré qu'il n'était pas du tout
protecteurs pour les salariés
et d'ailleurs c'est tout à fait étonnant
parce que on voit aux états unis qu'on a
des problèmes graves sur les systèmes
par capitalisation
avec pourtant des marchés financiers qui
sont plus haut qui la favorise on a le
fonds de retraite des camionneurs qui a
eu des problèmes très important qui va
couper les retraites des camionneurs le
fonds de retraite des des gens qui ont
des salariés du public en californie qui
a des gros problèmes
et si les marchés financiers baissent
ils sont plus haut on va avoir un vrai
crack du système je pense de retraite
par capitalisation aux états unis et
dernière chose c'est totalement idiot de
dire aux gens allaient dans un système
par capitalisation
ce qu'il faut bien placés dans des
actifs financiers or les taux sont à
zéro et ne rapporte rien l'immobilier
comme vous le savez est très très élevé
et donc est risqué il rapporte de moins
en moins et surtout la bourse est très
hot donc on va faire prendre des risques
considérables aux gens c'est peut-être
pour ça que ce que ressent le patron du
medef vis à vis des non cadres
alors le patron du bénef un geoffroy
roux de bézieux qui évoque aussi un
problème de compétitivité qu'est ce
qu'il entend par là que ce que l'on
pensait alors ce qui veut dire c'est que
les services publics la bonne protection
sociale est un atout important de la
france qui malheureusement c'est rod
mais qui est un atout important pour
attirer les gens effectivement il ya une
grande fluidité du marché du travail on
peut le regretter mais en tout cas c'est
comme ça et c'est français pourrait très
bien à ce moment-là partir à londres où
partir ailleurs avec un système qui
serait plus compétitif que celui de la
france
cette réforme des retraites aujourd'hui
elle a pris du plomb dans l aile une
nouvelle fois avec ses déclarations du
medef
oui elle a pris du plomb dans l'oeil de
puisque tout le monde est opposé un tous
les corps intermédiaires et les français
eux mêmes les citoyens français
eux-mêmes qui n'oublions pas que
monsieur jean michel blanquer n'a pas
répondu à quelque chose de fondamental
c'est que les profs aussi était très
concentré concernés puisqu'ils ont une
baisse de 25 % de la retraite sauf si on
augmente leur salaire avant
or le conseil d'état dans l'étude
d'impact a expliqué la semaine dernière
qu'il était impossible de garantir aux
enseignants une hausse des deux de leurs
salaires puisque si maintenant on veut
le faire sous son gant tequila pourquoi
pas mais on peut pas engager les futurs
présidents de la république à faire ce
qu'a dit macron en 2020 et qu'ils soient
obligés en 2025 d'augmenter le salaire
des profs dont qui ça c'est impossible
les professeurs ça va être un problème
et c'est vrai qu'on conclut on ne
comprend plus grand-chose à pourquoi
macron edouard philippe s'accroche à ce
système de retraite à cette réforme qui
finalement est contesté de tous côtés
en tout cas pour conclure il ya cette
conférence de financement qui a lieu
actuellement pour trois mois qu'est ce
qu'on peut en attendre est ce que ça
peut débloquer la situation selon vous
déjà ça
si un macron accepte de revenir sur ce
que de lui demande le medef c'est à dire
d'arrêter avec cette retraite des cadres
qui est amputé et ses cotisations qui
sont amputés ça veut dire que déjà sur
les 12 milliards à trouver il ya plus qu
il ya quatre milliards de moins donc il
ya plus que 8 milliards à trouver
après je veux dire est ce que les gens
vont accepter
vont accepter les syndicats vont
accepter il me semble qu'il ya pas grand
monde qui veulent accepter peut-être la
cfdt
et encore donc je ne suis pas du tout
sûr que cette conférence des retraites
sera sur un succès merci beaucoup
philippe furrer d'avoir partagé votre
analyse sur notre plateau je rappelle
que cet économiste
merci beaucoup